welcome everybody
and welcome to the panel thank you for
joining us and all of the people online
we're here to discuss the dance floor is
a political space
and just in case anybody like me was
wondering how do we get from politics
into this beautiful science venue
politics is in fact a science but what i
learned was it's an observational
science
not an experimental science
so in simple terms that means that no
experiments just research and
observations of behaviors to create
theories of politics
and we will start with introducing
ourselves with the people that are here
to discuss these theories with me
sarah hi steph
i'm glad that i can be here
my name is sarah farina i'm a dji
producer and activist and i'm a
co-founder of the
platform called transmission with dr
castine meisner who's a researcher and
transmission aims to make the political
and historical relevance up of club
music rave culture more audible and
visible
thank you nice to have you katherine
hi
as well for me nice to be here
my name is catharine arendt
i'm right now part of the club
commission i'm heading there the
department called awareness and
diversity so it's an apartment
department that is concerned on how to
make like club culture and clubs like
more diverse spaces and yeah especially
how to yeah change structures towards
this
and my background is i used to work
in
different
cultural spaces um industrial spaces
that were like reused to club spaces
for example in the ultimate and i used
to organize several festivals before
before i started to work for the club
commission
welcome
sebastian hi steph i'm very glad to be
with all of you here um i'm uh i'm
sebastian i'm a postdoctoral researcher
at the efu berlin
in the cluster of excellence
compensation of the liberal script i'm a
trained historian
i work on uh collective memories in the
transatlantic world so like germany the
us and canada i look at social movement
especially lgbtqi plus
movement and how
our memory is also constitutive of like
what we are uh today and i'm very glad
to be here today because before i moved
to germany and before i became a
historian i was i was also part of a
collective in montreal in canada having
a club
so we were having a medal and punk club
in the middle of the city so
excellent welcome
and i'm steph c and i run a company
called music mata and i am an artist a
label and an event manager and i do a
little bit of mentoring
i do a lot of business consultancy
and all pretty much mainly concentrated
in the music world and apparently today
i host a panel
okay so we've all come together because
we plan to share our experiences and our
opinions on club culture
and the fact that berlin and other
comparable cities have sounded the alarm
over the disappearance of alternative
spaces and clubs
as a symptom of fundamental change in
urban society
so basically we're going to delve into
what does it mean for liberal societies
when such places disappear become less
accessible or marginalized do they have
to be designed
can a society afford to lose such spaces
what can it do to retain them
and in addition to artists activists and
audiences what role can scientists
politicians or industry play
during our talk
we all come from totally different
worlds so
some of the definitions might differ
so we're just going to cover a few of
the words that you'll note out here
repeatedly just so that you can hear
what we actually mean when we use these
terms
so some of the words are that you'll
probably hear a lot it's community scene
dance floor
so
i'm going to start with sarah
as someone heavily active in the music
verse
do you agree with the statement that a
community includes people of all ages
including elders and kids and the scene
doesn't
and
if you don't agree or you do agree
what do the two words actually mean to
you
yeah that's a good question because i
think often those terms are used in the
same way but i think they mean something
different from each other and community
is what you just mentioned like you know
like an inclusive group where we focus
on the collective well-being and we
center the most marginalized people
um because when they're doing fine
everyone else is going to be fine as
well in my opinion and the scene is more
like um
about
ego economics and more strategies you
know and not really like
it's more about the individual
i believe so i think that's that's the
difference but i think a scene can come
together as a community sometimes
okay
what do they mean to you
um i agree with sarah that i think
they are often used in the same way but
means something different
for me actually i think that a scene is
a bit more
wider phenomena than a community and a
community can be part or is a part of a
scene for example when we think about a
club
i think a club space
whatever it might be is always like um
connected to a certain community and is
made yeah yeah around there you can find
a certain scene which is like made for
example out of artists producers of the
space and the crowd which then can come
together as a community but it's like
different things
so one community could have different
scenes yeah basically i think so yeah
okay sebastian anything to add um i mean
i basically agree with everything you
just said i would just add that a scene
is also sometimes very important for the
biography of some people so if i look at
my past and i look at the metal scene in
morial for example it was also my way of
meeting other people on the margin in in
the city and also then enter a community
i really like what you just said but i
think a community can also be part of an
exclusionary process so like a community
is definitely something that brings
people together in solidarity in one
direction and many direction but it also
exclude de facto other people especially
if we think for example the community of
the nation our community so when we talk
about a we we also talk about a dem so i
think there's also a problem there but
mainly it is about solidarity and it is
about
fighting for something
it's interesting you say that because
for me i think i've always used the word
seen as something that's quite closed
and quite cliquey whereas community to
me it's much broader and is more more
open
um and then the dance floor i know it
seems a very simple term
but what does the term dance floor mean
to you kathleen
so for me the dance floor
is actually a field of experimentation
and it's the core of club culture and
the core of a club but it can can
present itself in various ways i think
um but yeah it's kind of an arena of
self-expression and movement
anything different to that i love what
you just said i think i think for me um
it is space of course but it's also
communication so for me it's it shows
how communication is not necessarily
only with words but also with bodies
and just the fact of
having a dance floor or having the
possibility to go to a dance floor
is a privilege but it's also a way of
communicating with other people and i
think like when we're dancing in a club
in berlin
or elsewhere we are communicating with
people without talking to them at all
during the whole evening so for me it's
mainly buddies in communication and fun
and fun do you remember your first
memory of dancing
so dancing has always been part of my
life so i've been dancing ballet on some
tree
so i don't know where
my mom would probably say before tree
but i started my my classes when i was
three um so i don't know really i think
like my body has always been used to
dance like in a way of taking space and
taking up stage but uh what stage and
what stands for we're gonna talk about
it tonight today but so yeah i don't
really remember it's just it has been
part of my life although all my life
do you remember your first time
no
no
but i love everything everyone just said
and
i love that a dance floor can happen
anywhere
most of the time you know it's like you
just for me you just need a nice sound
system
and that also i'm claiming a dancer can
be a form of resistance you know
and
i'm always sometimes thinking like what
was the first for ever and i think
there's i think kirsten meisner my
friend from transmission she always says
that there's probably no culture that
hasn't invented dance or music since
sometimes i'm thinking of like
humans back in the days like really
really long ago uh they were maybe
drinking ayahuasca and dancing around
the fire maybe that was the first dance
floor i don't know
it's true um
i know if
somebody who did ayahuasca
and it's really interesting that you say
that because actually you almost feel
like it's internal
you actually you know the the dance
floor actually doesn't even need to
always be external i really felt the
music i
give away
i really felt the music inside and i
actually felt like i was dancing inside
which was a really unique experience
any first memories of dance
yeah so i just started to think about it
now and i try to remember and i
yeah i mean it's really strong in my
mind still i think i was 14 or 15 and
like i'm i'm coming from a very small
town in the middle eastern part of
germany
where like club culture was a very
different thing it happened in really
like abandoned places bunkers
and
really
under the surface so i remember i was 14
or 15 and i sneaked in with friends
in in such like a bunker um
away from in a village away from my town
and i wasn't allowed to be there i
really sneaked in because i was like way
too young and then they had like
house music playing and techno music
playing it was like the first
like
experience with that kind of music for
myself and i was like totally amazed how
it went into my body and how i would
like became one with a room
and felt like high on on sound and like
the vibrations so it was really strong
and yeah
i think it made me like passionate about
club culture until today yeah
so again something that connects us all
obviously everyone's very passionate
about the music and dancing
and that actually brings me on to
through history we've had so many
instances of dancing and the spaces that
allow community expression actually
being banned
you know caibo era ring dances during
the slavery times the illegal waves of
the 90s and of course the nazi era in
this wonderful clubbing capital that is
berlin
and today in the current covert pandemic
of course clubs and dancing was the
first thing that stopped
and it's been the last thing that we
have seen come back despite an industry
of 4.8 billion please don't quote me on
that number um
sebastian why do you think that we are
constantly having to defend the
relevance despite despite the cultural
financial spiritual and physical
benefits that we all just discussed
yeah i'm very i'm very happy stuff that
you were talking about um
so ring dance and capoeira uh i think i
just want to make first like a small um
a small comment about the country where
i come from so i think that when we talk
about the liberal state or we talk about
the nation state and we talk about
freedom it's always very important to
talk about who's freedom
um so i come from an ongoing colonial
project so canada since it's
since its start in 1870 when the
constitution was created uh excluded uh
first nations methi and inus from from
the borders of the liberal state and so
they also banned dancing and they banned
a whole bunch of stuff but they also
banned powwows dance and those kind of
stuff so even if the state canada is
always being presented as some kind of
you know model for the liberal state it
is also ingrained with the freedom but
also the non-freedom of others so i just
want to point that out
before i say anything but i do i do
think that we can learn from history
when we were discussing um the panel
before we met for today uh we're talking
about how sometimes we're stuck in the
present so there's a fight in berlin
right now but this fight is also
connected to fights in the past and if
we want to if we want to look at the
future and want to create some kind of
new utopias we also need to look at the
past and i think we've seen that a lot
in
covid time
i think tropes that were used before and
we're going to talk about the weimar era
a little bit later but um tropes that
were used before are used nowadays so
things that are always associated with
the margin are associated with only
pleasure and hiddenism is always the
first thing that goes and then we have
tropes from you know the 20s like this
idea of venereal disease or these ideas
of like oh but like we should not close
we should not reopen clubs because uh if
we open clubs like disease is going to
spread again like the way people talk
before covert about kitkat club as well
for example
so it's it's also interesting that you
know open office spaces have been
reopened like much faster than brothels
or that clubs and so there's something
here about who's in society is
considered to be contributing if we talk
about capitalism to the economy but what
is actually presented as a integrative
part of society and what is just
considered like pleasure and hiddenism
so i think it's very important to look
at the past in order to to understand
those kind of things and what is illegal
and what is accepted and what is not
accepted is also something that is
always connected with the past so
history i'm preaching for for my own
profession obviously i think history
helps us understand those things
so do you think history is also
responsible for why we're still fighting
do you think we're just not learning
from history because i hear you say
history is important but why does it
keep repeating itself if it's that was
the message in 1920
and here we still are
i think we can see that in two
directions i i don't think that history
definitely repeats itself and i sure
hope it will not if we talk about the
1920s and 30s um but we can learn
there's there's a there's a possibility
to learn about some things connected to
history so
i don't think the things are always
going to be the same i don't think for
example there was the el dorado and the
varma was a little bit like the bad guy
of the time i don't think that that the
same thing would happen to the bargain
for example i don't think that um we're
living in the same space as babylon
berlin for example but we can learn from
the past and we can learn from people
who fought not only from destruction but
we can also learn from people who banded
together created a community and
actually fought for something
and
berlin's very liberal known for that
can a society less if a society less
liberal
sorry is a society less liberal can't
read my own notes interesting is society
less liberal
if it has less liberal spaces
that's a very important and interesting
question i guess it would depend on like
how we define liberal which i don't
think is something we're gonna dive
we're gonna dive in today
um but i do think that it is
if we look at the liberal individual
freedoms i think it's very uninteresting
to see where we can have them and when
we can create them sometimes they they
pop up in spaces that we don't
necessarily await if we look at the gdr
for example which was not a liberal
state you had like church basement you
had like places where people actually
regrouped in order to create spaces and
create fight if we look at the lgbtqia
movement for example in the gdr um but
ingrained in the liberal state there's
also the destruction
of those liberal spaces i mean we see it
in berlin gentrification is part of
capitalism is actually one of the
mechanism of the liberal state so if we
if we see the muay thai or we see like
koopie and we see like those spaces that
are being taken away it is part
of
of the liberal state i would say
anything you two would like to add
having heard that
um
i'm just overwhelmed by all the
information
that's so interesting and so important
yeah
so i'll just think about your last
question if a liberal city becomes less
liberal if it's losing
liberal spaces um
on one hand i think yes um
but it's hard to say that and
on the other hand i think there will
always be
liberal spaces somehow because like
people find their way to connect and
to be progressive but i think
it's
it really matters how hard people have
to fight in order to create these
conditions and how much energy is left
to be really like progressive and think
forward and create new stuff
so
i think like taking away these spaces
it's like really
in some way
yeah speeding down the development
because yeah
i think you're really right there it
diverts the energy totally you can
survive but actually you could be doing
much more yeah if you had that energy
and which actually brings me to what you
were talking about basements you're
saying people will find spaces um you
said something on our chats before the
panel about kinship which was a new term
to me and but relating to the
connections and the relationships that
are basically formed on the dance floor
quite often
do you think sarah that kinship can
survive it's sort of the same question
but that it can survive and thrive
without the clubs where people go to be
themselves
i think we've seen this in the pandemic
that like when club spaces are closed
that it's really hard for a lot of
people because especially marginalized
people have their families there kind of
you know and like for me to dance for is
a way to practice hopefulness
that i'm like oh at least for a few
hours we can come together
and we're treating each other in nice
ways
and
yeah i'm so emotional today i'm on my
period
um uh but yeah i just
i'm emotional because like um
i don't understand how people
are seeing so many bad things in club
culture i'm like it's
it's it's so important to just be
you know and and with music it allows me
to just be and and be my true authentic
self without being in fear of
um
having to experience any form of
discrimination i'm talking about a
specific kind of dance form club setting
where we have
values where we um
focus on the most marginalized so
everyone gets to have that very
beautiful experience and then
and and i think that's the most
beautiful thing that can happen that
when people have that experience the
next day when they go back to their
daily life the things that i've learned
on the dance floor that they can take
that with them and implement that into
their daily lives and it can make us a
better people i think you know and also
just like this unity feeling
that you can have at a dance floor and
also what you mentioned that you know a
lot of the genres that people love so
much like house and techno that has been
so whitewashed
these genres or movements were often a
spiritual response to circumstances that
were often so brutal it's resistance
music and resistance is joy right but
like people are also tired um so um
there's a lot of work that we need to be
doing
and i think if anything if you lose the
spaces it does bring people together
more in a way but you're unable to do on
such a big scale whereas the dance floor
helps us bring people in that and not in
our immediate facility
talking about how you make those spaces
you said you're talking about a certain
dance floor and where you've
created a comfort for people and
everything's done equally
so the design of spaces is really
relevant and we're very lucky to live in
berlin and experience the vibes in so
many unusual spaces that you don't
really get in the rest of cities
um
so berliner specifically
because you're working for the club
commission and lots of other projects
maybe you could just tell us a little
bit about your work
yeah so
maybe
to start with what the club commission
is doing it's kind of an association
there's some working uh for the
interests of club culture and the actors
of club culture and berlin clubs
um and basically it's advocating so it's
advocating for
um conditions so clubs can still survive
in this environment we are living in and
existing in here in berlin
with all of these circumstances we
already talked about
and i mean
especially the pandemic i think really
brought to the surface how important it
is to have kind of an advocacy for that
kind of scene because it's coming from
the underground and it's somehow still
in the underground even though it's
commercialized and so on but there are
legal parts illegal parts and
um it's a very self-organized culture
and
it's really under the radar of
the general public i would say and we
could see this in the pandemic that it
just you know disappeared and it was
really important that so many people
did
amazing projects to
kind of keep club culture visible keep
these spaces visible and keep all of the
people and actors and producers in that
scene visible
and
it's really different compared to other
like spheres of culture like
institutionalized culture where i mean
we are here at the
natural museum it's uh heavily
governmentally funded and that's amazing
but that's really like a huge difference
when it comes to
preserving that here and
having a safe future so yeah so
basically the club commission and i'm
i'm working
for kind of yeah keeping that culture
visible and make it uh
yeah able to survive well thank you for
your work out of interest how big is the
club commission and how long has it been
established um
so we we celebrate at the end of this
year on december 2nd
the 20th anniversary of the club
commission wow it's crazy somehow
um
yep so
um
yeah
the idea started in the end of the 90s
and became an association in the
beginning of the 2000s and it's now
like i guess the biggest uh organization
of that kind worldwide like we have over
300 members
um constituted out of clubs and
collectives and
different people
and
i mean we are working in kind of we have
like an office team where we are
basically like 20 people and we have
like the same kind of amount of um
um
[Music]
yeah
an extended board and a board
um so we are all working together on
things yeah nice
um and i read that you were really
heavily involved in the
the ultimate
being repurposed for cultural events and
maybe you could just touch on that a
little bit more and also just cover the
benefits and challenges basically of
designing a space that is not meant
for entertainment and for clubbing of
course so i think my work at the
altamunza so maybe to explain that it's
an uh it used to be an abandoned old uh
coin mint
uh they used to produce like three
different uh
yeah veronin
um
currency exactly thank you
and then they stopped working there in
2006 and then it got abandoned no one
took care of it it's like a huge space
um overground and underground in the
myth of the city and
then
um
me
working in a collective we came from
like working for festivals together came
into that space and saw like a lot of
opportunities but there was actually no
infrastructure or anything it was just
an empty abandoned space with a lot of
potential and then we kind of yeah like
grassroots-like worked throughout the
different
rooms and just created stuff in order to
be visible and then to convince like the
state that we can stay there and this
was like kind of a puzzle from one room
to
another and
we tried to make work like different
disciplines of culture so like
studios um concerts but as well like
club events and trying to create a club
which then led me to my work at the club
commission because i really realized we
need advocacy and we really need people
to
fight for this culture to
stay in the center of the city
um yeah
it's a very nice story
how long did it take
it's still going on i mean it's now one
of the so maybe that's the interesting
thing so no one would like talk about
that space that much
in
2014 when we got there and then when
people start to do work in a space and
then more people are coming and then
it's coming to the surface and then
suddenly a lot of actors and you know
like stakeholders are interested in
spaces because actually it's an amazing
and one yeah one of the last real huge
buildings that have potential in the
city and then we came into this whole
like political process of okay now we
have to prove that we are allowed to be
here that we do important work because
there are all these other like
profitable ideas that could happen here
as well so it
became a fight kind of you know like a
cultural fight and it's still going on
and
luckily there have been like an
[Music]
um
public
participation process in order to bring
more cultural actors there and like
really look what's there what can stay
and
what can come
and so this process is ongoing and
really not at the end
would you say one of the biggest
challenges was what you just mentioned
basically capitalism and the money that
could come in it is yeah yeah
and it's i think it's really depending
on what kind of government we have uh
and who is taking care of that issues
any of you want to dip in on that yeah
capitalism
i'm not sure we have time to talk about
but yeah always money well it's actually
really relevant to you because when i
investigate what you're up to um i was
reading the bios on the two platforms on
transmission transmission says that the
mission is to make the political
relevance and history of international
sound club and rave culture audible and
visible
and then emergent base which i believe
is your latest project from this year
um thank you for
you posted to say thank you for sharing
um your extremely valuable thoughts with
us and fighting to make club culture
more enjoyable and safer reminding us
that coalitions in the german club music
scene beyond berlin between bipark and
queer club music artists djs collectives
etc are so necessary and in order to let
culture community and people thrive in
sustainable ways
and i think it's what you were talking
about earlier when we were talking about
spaces and survival
were your platforms and your work of
designing these spaces is it because you
felt it was missing
yeah i think that it always comes out of
the urgency right and just like wow
no one is doing so i have to do it
basically but of course there are people
before us there are people fighting for
those spaces and so on and we just want
to continue that at the end of the day
but fights they change from time to time
and the situations change and
governments change
so yeah with emergent base for example
i was invited by kami and karo
two music lovers they had this idea of
creating a new interdisciplinary
event series called imagine base at
manchester maya which is a very
political club here in berlin
to center the aphrodisporic music
culture and queer culture as well like a
space um
buy us for us basically because of
course my the next step would be to have
a
club for our own just us so we don't
have to
um
you know uh collaborate i mean it sounds
bad but you know what i mean
when you say earth you mean you're
collective yeah bring these things
together yeah yeah just like but imagine
like this utopian uh utopia club where
it's
run by uh by park people and queer
people and that doesn't exist enough in
my opinion
because often if you work in uh white uh
lead or male heteronormative
institutions you'll hit a glass ceiling
at one point
and
it's it's it's just very
it makes you tired you know and it's
it's interesting because since last year
black lives matter
people are kind of trying to do the work
now i think but there's a lot of
performance as well and
you know i get that in some context
it's like um
uh
you're trying to learn something new and
then you perform maybe for a while until
you really get it but i'm now at like
those thank you till
fake it till make it
but these fights have been going on for
a long time and people really need to
get their [ __ ] together
um to do better you know and um it's
kind of crazy to think about that
george floyd had to be murdered until we
have a discussion about racism in
germany and it's still in baby shoes
this whole discussion it also links to
the whole history of nazi germany and
people really not coping with the
responsibility and all the things that
have happened
because it was an opportunity to to deal
with those things
um
but there are wonderful people in the
city who are doing amazing work for sure
and
i think emerging base can be
a space where we practice the things
that we wish for already today right now
in a way
nice and when you're when you're
creating these events and these spaces
basically designing them to fit your
needs what's at the forefront of your
mind
um it's
like you also said like you know we're
trying to educate ourselves with history
to understand them now better in order
to have a more inclusive and safer
future i think that's key and it's also
not like that our group
knows everything we're also learning
along the way it's it's kind of like
we're inviting people into the process
to learn together and not like being
preachy about anything
and you know i spent some time in
detroit with underground resistance
who's like
underground resistance is a black
collective techno collective that is
very political and they really
activated my political values even more
than before so that also really shaped
me and i feel like i have this
responsibility also to work in
intergenerational ways to um
honor
the people who have been fighting for us
so we are
there where we are right now so we can
continue the fight and um
you know it's like about um the that we
wanted to have an inclusive diverse
stands for but that also should reflect
in the lineup and in the structure
itself
because and we don't talk about the
structures enough it's it's kind of easy
to to curate a
diverse lineup it's very easy or what
about the structures you know
because we don't want to reproduce um
the harmful systems
so when you say structures what do you
what exactly do you mean like
hierarchies for example or just like how
we show up for each other or not show up
for each other how we talk to each other
it's like sometimes just
microaggressions and we all have to
learn a lot of things
um but it's especially marginalized
people who really
are being oppressed in systemic ways and
um it's it's weird because
people love to go out to dance to our
music to our culture
but
they don't do the work and don't
understand where it comes from or don't
honor it enough they just want to have
the good bits basically you know just
like there's this um quote like people
love um black culture but not black
people
you know it's
it's it's really sad but i think
it it's also fun to learn about those
things you know it's it's it makes you a
better raver
to know where the music comes from and
the people behind the music and what
kind of um
spirituality is behind it you know and
how it like and then we are back at the
to the body topic like how you can
uh get to know your body in different
ways on a dance floor and with movements
and so on
and especially if you're comfortable
right if you're in a safe space the way
you dance is completely different to how
you dance when you feel on edge or
you're slightly uncomfortable exactly
and i think
one of the important things is if you
work in the music industry or in the
club scene is to hold yourself
accountable as well it's always easy to
point to others like you're doing it the
wrong way and and so on it's important
to hold other people accountable
but also have to hold myself accountable
as a dj because i have a certain amount
of power as a dj um if you're in a
certain amount of league i would say
especially
the elitist djs they they play for a lot
of money
imagine if they would use more
inclusivity writers when
they would have
something like inner writers that would
say i'm only playing
club gigs or festivals if you have that
amount of
nominary people trans people women
bipark people in the lineup otherwise
i'm not playing or if you're a white dj
for example
and you're playing afro house music you
know
maybe there's a way that 10 of your fee
goes back to the community
you know i think it's it's kind of easy
to be less
shitty it is
and with your events are you teaching
people this kind of stuff is that why
you've
combined panels with an event because
you're trying to talk to people about
these things exactly so daniel schneider
from archive of youth cultures in berlin
and we were curating the panel
discussions like one of the topics was
how
black music culture has a shape berlin
club culture for example with the gi
disco
culture and so on and those panels for
example they're they're all in um in
german
and we also had people who would
translate from german to english to make
it more accessible
and just learn together at the end of
the day but also i'm at a point where
right now sorry to say this where i
question the panel format
um
sorry sorry no it's been cancelled
it's just we need more um something that
is interactive you know where we really
because sometimes people just listen and
they go home and then nothing happens
but i want to find more ways where we
can actually do something and have like
tools you know so we're thinking of ways
at emergent base to um
uh create different forms of coming
together with the community
and yeah talking is important i love
this yeah very thankful to be here but
more action yeah more action yeah um i
actually have a friend who recently did
a panel for um
october
um
and basically
she decided to do a quiz instead of a
panel
because she said in the panels we're
just talking at people we're just
preaching and the quiz was a fun quiz
but it was so people had take away facts
and could actually educate themselves
so i think that can be quite interesting
but even though you're bored by the but
not bored or questioning the panel um i
really like the idea of going to events
where i get
a little bit more engagement with the
artists and the people that have put the
dance on and you can have a chance for
feedback right it's a back and forth
conversation
and these multi-purpose spaces i
actually wanted to ask you about this
sebastian um i read about a place called
mocha fd way before my time he was too
i'm assuming
um but it was a really extravagant i
don't know how many of you have ever
heard of it but it was a really
extravagant multi-functional space
and not with panels and dances but
apparently it had barber shops
a beccarei
and even a room filled with typists for
businessmen and journal journalists if
they needed to pause and work because
often it was two to three day
parties and i'm just curious whether
there's anything to learn from these
these spaces or whether it's something
that should be left in the past
combining
activities
i think this is already happening in
berlin actually that was one of the
first thing that struck me when i
arrived in berlin that there was food in
clubs and that there was you know a
possibility to to stay
like the party being a conversation and
being a dialogue during a whole weekend
in order to stay there uh sometimes with
the help of something more than food but
like you have food
in order to sustain yourself i
i think that um so this is an example
from from the 20s right from the from
the 30s but
i really like what you what you said
before about and you also mentioned it
when you were talking about the bunker
spaces um there's there's places
that were taken away during this
pandemic that were really important for
people
um that so when we always talk when we
talk about feminist theory queer theory
and those kind of stuff we always talk
about the private being politics but
sometimes we we also forget that the
private the home for some people is also
a place of violence
and it's not necessarily the place where
they can you know fulfill who they are
or actually like be who they are and
then places outside of their home become
the private space where those people
thrive right so we have like chosen
family you were mentioning chosen family
and i think like clubs
is that for a lot of people and so
staying a whole weekend in a club with
food with dance with uh with multiple
aspects is not necessarily just party
and just pleasure but it's also family
and it's also
i don't want to use religious term but
also a communion kind of with like
different kind of people
and it depends also how we see the dance
floor but for me the dance floor is not
only dancing it's also when we talk
about pleasure and desire it's also sex
and i think um
when we talk about those things
sometimes we don't talk about sex but a
lot of a lot of the clubs in berlin with
dark rooms are with you know improvised
dark rooms also spaces where people have
orgies have sex are touching each other
and this is also part of you know
people creating who they are and being
part of who they are so there's already
multiple aspects of the dance floor you
can dance but you can also you know you
can have sex and you can kiss and you
can flirt and and for some people it's
the only way that they can do this
especially if they just move to berlin
for example but we also have other
spaces where where people are mixing all
those stuff together if we think about
the foots for example which is i think a
very good example people were so happy
to reopen
last weekend um
but the schwutz i mean some people don't
know this but it started in the 70s and
it actually comes from uh giliberation
and the schwenberg in in germany so it
started as a small space from the
homosexual accent west berlin which i
think there's going to be a jubilee own
party and foots in in a couple of weeks
to celebrate the 50 years um of the avi
but this this this was a communal space
from the beginning and then it moved to
queensbank and now it moves to narcon
but it it is already a space where
people were were talking and and
is doing so much political events for
example mensch my eyes doing a lot of
political informa informative events
where you can learn about antifa
politics for example you can learn about
um
various aspects of things that are
usually in academia
who are like share among people who are
actually living those things so like not
talking about but talking with and then
afterwards you stay in the club and then
you just dance the the night away so
this is this is already
happening and last point i mean there's
a lot of like left-wing spaces in berlin
who also offer food in different kind of
ways right if we think about popular
kitchen
all the house projects in berlin who
some of them were legalized some of them
are still not legalized who are actually
opening their doors sometimes more than
once a week to offer food for people for
like two or three euros like um
so-called like
and i mean this is like in a society
that is so divided by class
like germany
um it is very interesting to see like
different kind of people kind of like
meeting around food i mean maybe it's
etobic and it doesn't work like this all
the time there's also processes of
exclusion but people are meeting to talk
about food to eat food and then staying
for an informative event and then why
not for a dance party afterwards so i
think this is still happening and it's
very brilliant i think very brilliant
i've never seen a barber but i've
definitely seen
a few things come together
and that's very specific to berlin but
sarah you visited lots of cities and
countries to share music you teach
workshops and to collaborate with other
artists and dance in their clubs have
you experienced somewhere with an
absence of the spaces that we've been
talking about so cities that just don't
have it
and what's the impact on the people
there in the society
actually i have to think of my own
hometown
i'm from south germany i come from a
small town there
which is like two hours from munich and
so i grew up there it's bavaria very
conservative
you know i went to a catholic girls
school
this was a very intense experience and
they i think they still have just one
club and it's like a very mainstream
um
club for teenagers like something
sometimes you're allowed to get in when
you're 16 like i don't know abby party i
don't know how to say this in english
um graduation well not exactly
graduation but yeah unlikely spring
breakers you know what i mean yeah and
um
yeah
from my perspective not really a music
culture or anything it was just more
about
i don't know getting really drunk and
i don't know i just couldn't uh connect
with it
and uh just really no music education i
think just consuming
you know
and um
[Music]
and i mean the bavaria itself just it
makes sense that
we had this kind of club and it hasn't
really changed until now so yeah that's
why i'm here now that was going to be my
question when you go home to visit has
it changed at all not really i think no
i've never played
maybe maybe i should do my own way there
well that's kind of what was on my mind
thinking the space doesn't exist maybe
you create it i'm sure there are cool
people there there's always a few people
who um
have a similar mindset i guess and
now i'm here you know i mean since a
long time but like that's that was one
of the reasons because i didn't feel a
sense of belonging
i think that's very
um uh
central to to club culture you have a
sense of belonging or what you just
mentioned people feel like they're home
and i don't didn't really feel home in
that kind of club space but i've never
really been to a place where there's no
club culture at all i think we're also
speaking about the specific kind of club
culture here right i mean there's also
club culture with bottle service and vip
area that's something else
it's very much something else but very
popular but not actually so much not
sure if we consider this club culture i
mean that's something to discuss like
really yeah
maybe another time
[Laughter]
but staying focused on the spaces
you've been really um
well this year for anybody who's not
aware um
german reunification day the third of
october
was actually repurposed
for target club call tour
and
you worked on that
and i'm just curious in the climate of
these women number of spaces
disappearing how did it feel in this
time to unite and give a voice to so
many artists and so many venues in
support of berlin's club culture
well first of all i have to say we
didn't you know like uh
we didn't change the day in the
reunification day we just thought it's
like a very good occasion to have a day
to celebrate club culture especially
when we look at the history of club
culture in the city and that it really
um kind of you know like evolved in in
the time when the wall went down and
like there were a lot of abandoned
spaces and
um like a progressive culture could
develop so we just thought it's like
yeah an amazing day to to celebrate our
scene and so
the day of club culture is an initiative
from
the cultural senate and the club
commission and the music board and it
basically
took place the first time last year so
in the midst of the first row of the
pandemic and
when really nothing could happen
and
so basically in that october last year
the day of club culture was the first
day when really stuff could happen in
clubs again under like
certain measurements and circumstances
of course but it was really the first
day the whole scene could come together
could go back to their work could
hire their artists present their own
curated programs and express themselves
and
[Music]
invite their crowd
and that was really what happened like
all the
it's like 40 places all over the city
who get awarded with kind of an yeah
price or award of 10 000 euros and it's
really like something very symbolic so
like saying
we see you and we consider your culture
and we
really appreciate what you are doing to
the city and we as well acknowledge that
without you and all of the people
the city wouldn't be the same so it was
really like a political and symbolic act
and of course like financial help that
was really needed in that time but i
guess it's really way more of yeah again
making the scene visible and appreciated
because it's really like an extension
part of the city and the cultural life
here so last year was really
um amazing like really like emotionally
moving
and
um
it's as well you know like a huge
paradigm shift
for the culture to be
yeah
considered by the cultural senate in
berlin and which really means something
because we have this issue that still we
are kind of fighting in society for
club culture being considered as a part
of real culture and of course we all
here are sure about that and now like of
course like
thank god like
politicians as well but still in the
common sense of society we always have
to prove that we are worth it and that
we are really doing cultural work so
this was like a big big step
and
same happened this year and as well the
focus of the day of club culture is
especially on the diversity
of the actors in the scene so the
diversity of the clubs and their
programs and their approach and the
collectives
and what kind of you know um
engagement
they
they have in
in the society work and
what kind of special ideas they bring to
the city and moving it forward so i
think it's a really special and
emotional thing
and which made a lot of people very very
happy um
and being like appreciated the first
time in their life for the work they are
doing for so long did you feel that
there was a difference because of the
pandemic and everything had happened did
was there any more energy like more
momentum because people had realized
what it felt like to lose it and then
come back
so it's really different how it happened
last year and how it happened this year
and i remember i had a conversation with
zara about it as well because last year
as i said it was really the first huge
event when things in our club spaces
could happen all over the city so
everybody was really excited like the
crowd and the people doing it and they
would like generally just overwhelm all
the places because they didn't dance for
so long and they didn't
came together with their community
especially and you could really feel
that you know like people were crying
and this year it was really like in the
middle of a very very stressful summer
because
things stopped for over one and a half
years and then suddenly in june we could
start doing things again you know in
summer open air and um
suddenly a whole scene
had to go back to work from doing
nothing and having like a huge
existential crisis and looking for stuff
because a lot of people you know like
found new jobs and we are looking in a
whole different landscape now but um
still we have to go back to our work and
that's what we want to do but yeah
suddenly from one second to another we
were there again it was so like fast and
powerful and there was no
place and time and space for resonance
and like feeling yourself and then
in the midst of that stressful thing the
day of club culture happened so i really
felt this year
it was
even more important that we had off
something like a really crazy award show
where we could all dress up come
together and show ourselves and
hold the price and being happy and then
it was just an add-on to have this like
day of club culture on october 3rd
happening
but it didn't have
the same feeling as the last year just
because we were again in a different
situation so thinking now about it um
and that's coming back to the talk i had
with sarah about it we would reconsider
it and maybe even
making it a month of day of club culture
or something like this you know because
now we have all these
stuff already going on clubs are opening
again and
we don't have the urge you know to
reopen things
for now i mean we really don't know in
what future we are looking and what will
happen in the next month and
if we found find ourselves back in the
situation again
it's very true we've got no idea of
what's going to happen and also i think
that it's still very fresh what's just
happened
um but it whenever i think about like
losing these spaces and what just
happened going back in history and
talking about the way my republic and
the fact that berlin had this amazing
reputation
um
i actually read that there was a popular
guidebook
to
a lesbian in berlin advertising readers
that there was something for everyone in
this city
here each can find their own happiness
for they make a point of satisfying
every taste so berlin obviously already
had that but if you could tell us a
little bit about having lost that
and what it meant and how we've learned
from that or what's changed and what
hasn't changed
um
so weimar has always been a big topic in
berlin right even like when i look in
the archives and i do look at things
that were happening or i read um for
example
for anybody who doesn't know what it is
maybe you could just of course one
sentence of what period of time it
relates to him with it so we're talking
about the period of grosso model between
the two world wars so after after the
end of the german empire and before the
rise and taking of power of the nazis
it's called the republic of weimar
because the republic was declared in
varma which is a town in
turin in the center of germany
um
yeah so it's called the varma era
and when i look at the archives and i do
work about about this this period it's
always fantastic to to to make
connections with the present and
basically look at the way people were
talking about uh if you're crazy you
should go to berlin because this is this
is where it's where it's happening
um
but i think that we we also forget the
darker aspect of of weimar so like this
scene was driving and there was a little
bit something for a lot of people i
wouldn't say for everyone but there was
something for a lot of people there was
a queer scene that was also very big uh
in in germany at the time
um but there was also a lot of police
raids there was a lot of like uh lists
compiled by uh by the police forces
there was a lot of surveillance i think
there's a reason why the national
socialists were able to destroy a scene
quite easily afterward because a lot of
surveillance had always been taking
place during that time but what i'm very
interested is the memory of of those
things i think this is how what's really
important for us today as well so if if
i give one example um at nolenov platz
which is a
um for those of us of you we're looking
at a live stream that are not
necessarily based in berlin it's a it's
a station in the middle of berlin in the
borough of schunebach
there's a there's a ping triangle on
that station it's a memorial to the
memory of the homosexual victims of the
national socialists and one of the
reason why this triangle is there it was
inaugurated in 1989 one of the reason
why this triangle is there is that
schuneberg was basically won a very
important borough for
for the community back then and there
was a lot of clubs that were that were
there like gay clubs but also lesbian
clubs uh who got destroyed and i think
this commemoration of the destruction by
the nazis of those club is very
important for many aspects but one
aspect that's very important is how we
talk about this destruction so usually
when we talk about victims like
homosexual victims of the national
of the national socialist we're talking
about gay men because there was a there
was a law that criminalized uh sex
between men paragraph 175 but lesbians
were oppressed as well more structurally
maybe but they were oppressed as well so
that we commemorate the fact that
lesbian clubs were also destroyed show
that we can also commemorate the more
structural violence
connected to fascism the most structural
part of power and i think this is very
important when we look at the past and
we look at those culture but we've been
talking a lot about bunkers and
abandoned places today and i think this
is also connected to this history and
the violent history of berlin so the
fact that we're allowed to have those
spaces that we have bunkers that we have
abandoned places is a very wonderful
thing but it's also connected to a very
darker past of history right it's
connected to history of oppression of
genocide of anti-semitism of racism and
i think that is very important to take
into consideration when we talk about
survival of the scene so there's a
positive aspect of this survival i
really love that you said that joy is
resistance like there is there is
something there but there's also this
violence that's kind of like connected
to it and i feel obliged also because
we're in natural condo museum today to
also mention that this violence had also
various aspects and when we talk about
the weimar republic and we talk about
who were guests in those club and those
there was also a lot of freak show
happening in those clubs a lot of like
people who were shown as kind of
entertainment exhibited exhibited and
usually those were bipoc individuals
were also sometimes kidnapped um and i
think it's very important to talk also
about who the entertainment was for who
and a little place for everyone yes but
who was a freak
and who was considered a freak do you
think that those negative memories are
also what helps cities survive or come
back after that like did berlin
you know recover and is it the negative
memories that
that feed it
i'm a it's not that i'm a very negative
person but i'm a huge fan of how the
negative can actually push us further i
think there's different way of looking
at the negative past we can just like
look at how problematic it was or how
how it doesn't conform to some values
that we have nowadays but we can also
see something
to learn from it right and there's
something
to be aware of it like when we talk for
example of queer politics of lgbtqi plus
politics we're always kind of this in
frame of like from shame to pride and
from like negative to positive and going
out there but there's also something
like very important and driving at
actually looking shame and pain and
suffering in the face and actually
learning from it so i think club culture
learns from his past and it's also very
important
anybody have anything to say to that
yeah just it just
i mean
it's a good reminder that we need to
look at the past in order to understand
the the now better
it's it's always the same and um yeah i
think it's a pattern that we very much
see it's kind of an arrogance of we can
do it fresh
we can do it better without actually
you can do it better you can improve but
how do you know what you're improving on
without going back and looking at what
went wrong yeah but i think it has as
well something to do with like the
psychological immune system of people
you know like to like really
suppress and um
look a
uh from stuff that is somehow as well
painful and look somewhere different
it's not very productive but
i think that happens as well like
people tend to forget what is painful
kind of a survival technique or
protection more inner protection so to
not have to deal with it and as well in
the here and now not just in the back
and then i think in the here and now we
as well have to always think about both
sides like now we are like celebrating
club culture here and it's something
very beautiful that connects us all but
it has
as well like the darker side um
which because it is ingrained and
embedded in an all over
power dynamic of society in capitalism
and social inequality and these are as
well all the challenges
we have to face as well in our spaces
the beautiful they are
yeah
talking about that um so in terms of the
spaces that we actually have
already
um with gentrification making us lose
lots of them
is there a chance to utilize the spaces
that we have
in the absence of opening new ones how
do we make them safe spaces if you i
mean you already do it with your events
but when you say when you were talking
about the structure and the setup how do
you make it what your class is a safe
space
yeah i would even
say
use the term safe first basis because a
safe space is it's not possible right i
wish
but
nothing will ever be perfect you know
and
i think a lot of the things have to do
they have to do with ourselves i think
it's looking inward
even on a spiritual level almost like i
think anti-racism
work or anti-able uh ableism work
um
[Music]
is is
um not it's political but also spiritual
in a way because you have to
um
look at yourself and be like oh i did
things wrong and maybe you kind of feel
fragility of your ego
because you feel shame and it's
uncomfortable but we only grow outside
of our comfort zone i guess and
you can do that by yourself maybe by
reading books and and taking part in
workshops or whatever and i feel like
there are different forms of being a
more
um what's what impartish um
[Music]
empathic person
empathetic yeah empathetic person um and
you know like with club commission you
started the awareness academy for
example you can talk about that later um
where there's now more structure and and
um
things where people can go to who work
in the club industry to
create better parties at the end of the
day because i think if you know how to
take care of people in more sustainable
ways you will have better parties at the
end of the day and more joy
and
who is against joy
i i don't i don't
i hope no one
but i'm sure there is
um
and
yeah with with the merchant base we also
try to hold ourselves accountable and
for me as an artist you know i'm trying
to
look inward all the time and ask myself
critical questions and they're
uncomfortable
but i think that's how i grow and find
my authenticity and sometimes i don't
know the answers but it's it's important
for me to know why am i doing this am i
in there just because i want money and
fame or
is it for me
about bringing people together from
different backgrounds and
i'm sharing music with people and you
know i i describe my music as rainbow
bass because for me music is a spectrum
and i think it's also interesting in
club culture or in berlin
we have different floors and it's like
the techno floor and this is hip-hop i'm
like why is this genre segregation
happening because we're also segregating
people
and then there are hierarchies
everywhere and
in my utopia we don't think in those
categories so much because they're harm
people right i know that to some extent
people need categories but we also know
how much harm they have been doing to
put people in boxes and how we
internalize those things
and i described my music as rainbow
rainbow bass because space is the
essence right it's what we feel in our
body it's what makes makes people
uh scream
when the bass kicks in
and it's something so universal that
people react to with their buddies and
rainbow because for me the different
music genres that
that are out there they're all connected
to each other like the colors in the
rainbow and there's also queerness in
there you know and music has traveled
also for very terrible reasons like
you know colonial history and so on
but there we are again at this point of
you know that
the genres that have uh evolved out of
resistance you know that it's so joyful
like bella funk for example or tech
known house music
um
yeah i think i lost my
red thing uh
linear but you know what i mean you
actually answered the question um yeah
but talking more physically actually
about retaining these spaces because
everything i hear from you is beautiful
in terms of your crew and how you step
into spaces and what you try and create
and but do the spaces that we already
have have some responsibility
to improve things because i don't think
it's just the dance floor or just the
collective that's hiring a venue you
know what about the door staff what
about the actual management the whole
infrastructure of the space
you know
can we do better there to actually
improve the spaces and it brings me on
to to you catherine because you were um
you're always
working in spaces but also
[Laughter]
i was trying to like yeah i'm trying to
figure out do you think in berlin and
with the club commission is it even ever
an issue to talk to clubs in the bigger
picture of their whole structure
um it is i mean that's i guess the core
of my my work i'm doing there um
but maybe just uh to refer something you
said like to the term of safer spaces i
think
as well it's maybe a good idea to
replace it uh with something like
intentional space like really like
what's our intention when we create this
space because it makes clear that
there's a certain responsibility
as like
someone who runs a club a collective who
creates parties or
whoever has any you know like task in
that we have a responsibility on how we
create the space what we decide for who
we invite and which kind of you know
like code of conduct we apply how we
take care of each other and what are
our consequences if something is going
wrong and i think that's really missing
that a lot of
clubs
and
i don't know promoters
collectives they don't really have this
kind of you know like idea on yeah what
is actually how do we consider when
something is going wrong as something
wrong and what do we then in the
aftermath how do we treat it what is our
ethic behind it so
um
and i think it is changing really as
well
um there's a lot of work to do i totally
agree like it's really endless right now
but still things are moving
and
as well because of the yeah over aching
society
that is changing you know like people
are more aware um
suppressed voices raise their voices
they point out
problematic situations and we see this a
lot in club culture and
we as club commission with awareness
academy the project i'm taking care of
we really try to create conditions and
structures in order to give them like
club owners club staff door staff
possibility to educate themselves um to
learn
in these fields
and as well to have a dialogue and
exchange between them because they can
learn a lot from each other but it's as
well segregated there you know like
every club is doing their own stuff
but they don't talk to each other
because they that this is like this very
neo-liberal
you know mindset like this is our thing
we are fighting for
um
for our position but actually they could
really change something and if they
would work more together and exchange
more and we see this in all like the
offerings we are doing like we do a lot
of workshops that are always you know
like
oriented on
what
clubs are asking for or what is right
now the issue in the scene what are we
talking for so we had a lot of
[Music]
workshops and trainings on racism and
club culture and how can we change our
communication how can we take care of
each other how can we
um
yeah be more responsible
um
sexism sexualized violence is a huge
topic and
as well like classism ageism all these
things going on so there's a lot for all
of us to learn and all we can do is like
really just offer
um options and
i think a huge problem we see is
that there is a lack of resources like
working in club culture is precarious
itself it's like not
paid well
the working conditions are problematic
and
as well you know like the mental
physical and financial capacity to
to train your stuff
to make this possible is really
challenging so we try really to
have like a program that is for free so
whoever wants to attend who is an actor
in the scene can attend and
[Music]
that's what we are doing ongoing and who
does attend out of curiosity the fact
that it's available how do you
communicate it to people to the
community to everybody
so throughout it because often i find in
these talks the people that are aware of
these things are not actually the people
that need to learn
that's pretty cool that you are asking
this because um i'm doing this now for
two years so we started the awareness
academy as kind of an institution two
years ago and
the thing changed like the whole
like yeah
situation changed so in the beginning we
really had to run after club owners club
workers like here we have this like
training on awareness and sexism don't
you want to
attend um
we would call them nobody would attend
and then it really changed like from in
the beginning we had like just like the
very awoke and aware people who already
doing the work in the clubs and now we
really see
it's more diverse like really people who
have um never dealt with this topics are
coming now club owners are coming now
and i think it's as well because
then
we kept on doing this work and we never
got tired communicating it all over the
place and
people would attend would tell other
people and as well you know like it
raised kind of a trust so in the
beginning a lot of people were like okay
like this is public funded money you are
giving us this trainings now you want to
teach us something this is totally
against like the essence of club culture
as well we don't want to you know like
expose ourselves to the government like
all these kind of uh suspicion we could
see there so it really changed that
they're now realizing okay this is just
something
we can use for our advantage and we can
really change something and as well you
know like society is working for us
because they realize we have to change
something
in order to be ready for the future and
to be still there
so certain factors coming together it's
really comforting to actually know that
that's happening i don't know if it's
happening in many other cities but it's
really impressive that you guys are
doing that um and it kind of brings me
to the point of the fact that
we always it's always the same people
you know it's kind of it's artists
activists and audiences with these
academies and going to them
but i we we should talk about what role
can scientists politicians
and the industry play as a whole and
what you already touched on is it's
great that this academy is happening but
i'm also curious before we move on to
that point how many people have attended
the academy
that's a good question so we have like
workshops going on every month and each
workshop has like between 20 and 30
people
so over
um a time frame of two years it's a lot
and sometimes you have even more in one
month so this month for example it's
very busy we have like four trainings on
different fields like um
[Music]
violent free communication
um
critical masculinity um awareness
training and bystanderism stuff like
this so and it's always totally
overbooked so that is really what
changed as well you know in the
beginning we would really have to find
people to attend and now we have like a
waiting list we could fill three other
trainings so you could can really
see like the landscape changing
that's yeah it's really interesting um
so yeah going back to my question and i
interrupted myself asking you about the
numbers
but what role can scientists politicians
or the industry play sebastian well i
think hearing what you were saying right
now which is very encouraging to hear
um i think so i come from a background
of queer studies and
feminist studies and like what we hear
in the media most of the time is that
those niche programs or those niche
studies are actually something always in
the ivory tower and no one is caring
about this and actually it's completely
disconnected from like the rest of the
population which is not true if we look
at actually grassroots organization and
things that are happening in those kind
of communities and i think that the
teaching moment that you were talking
about is very important like
understanding that communicating between
each other means that we're not always
trying to just make statements and
proving points but that we have a
dialogue and i think scientists can
bring that a lot like we can we can
bring the various studies that we have
been writing the different kind of topic
that we've been discussing and bring
other people into conversation as much
as we learn as well from people on the
ground so there's a there's a there's a
dialogue here that's very important and
it breaks this idea of
liberal progressive wokism that is
actually completely disconnected from
the population which is which is not
true because people actually want to
have joy and want to dance and want to
want to feel safer um
so i think there's there's that
but at the same time i mean there's a
lot of survey that are being done in
university there's a lot of studies that
are being done there's a there's a
dialogue here it it it's very
encouraging what you're saying basically
there's a survey that you talked about
in our prep for this panel can you tell
us a little bit more about that
yeah right now we are working with our
project awareness academy at a um
on a survey we will release it
beginning of next month our end of this
month
which is basically researching
[Music]
incidence of discrimination and the
systematic and quantity of it in berlin
club culture and as well
how it's connected to individual
satisfaction and as well
what is like the social significance for
individuals of club culture
so in order to see yeah what are we
actually dealing with where
are things going wrong in what way on in
which dimension and but as well what
kind of you know like value has club
culture at the same time because it's
it's always these both sides it's um
it's like a safer space or intentional
space for marginalized communities at
the same time we
we know the reality of discrimination
going on especially against
these kind of groups and so
we really want to see
the balance between and as well you know
like where are really the problematic
points in the club where we have to do
something about it but especially what
can do science so we can create facts
uh scientific facts and then we can work
with these kind of facts you know we can
publish them we can say this is the
reality um
and then we can go you know like to the
government and the to politics and say
and in order to change something or in
order to pre-save these facts preserve
these facts we we need that we need that
kind of resources we need that kind of
fundings or we really need to have this
like public discussion
so it can i think it's a really fruitful
connection and it should happen way more
and as well the number you said in the
beginning you know like the economical
it comes from our club culture study we
we released
in the end of 2018.
not me but
like a very ambitious team and in the
club commission did that research and uh
i mean it was i think groundbreaking in
that term that we then had like this
economical facts
besides we were like
researching on social dimensions
cultural dimensions and stuff like this
but the economical factor we had then as
a fact was really important in order to
be able to address a lot of people
in powerful positions to say okay like
this industry is an industry it matters
it's a huge number
and at the same time it's a culture and
it belongs to each other but we really
matter so to not lose it you have we
have to do something all together
and
so yeah
so these surveys
sorry if if i may add to this i think
that like when we talk about science and
we talk about surveys we all we we often
think about uh quantitative
research but i think qualitative
research is also important so you're
mentioning
um this amount of money what was it for
eight eight billion so there's the
economic aspect and this is very
important those facts are very important
but you were also mentioning a lot of
like the spiritual aspect of the dance
floor and i think if we look at
qualitative research and we show how
emotions and feelings of belonging are
important in the club culture there's
this other way the politics can also
look at the importance of club culture
and not only just hard fact which are
important but also like other kind of
facts that are based on other kind of
research which are as scientific as 100
yeah but how do we take these this
research and these findings and turn
them into change
in berlin specifically do you have open
ears
in the government i know the fact that
it's all linked but with the change of
government too i'm just curious
how the business is i really think that
changed a lot like how
the club commission has an ear from the
government especially through the
pandemic we really became like a voice
for a very diverse and decentralized
scene
and it's very complicated you know like
to communicate needs of that kind of
group
that is made of so many places
um
to one direction so that's where the
club commission comes in and is kind of
making translation work for the needs
towards
the government and
that could really it really brought a
change i mean we have had we we see all
the help clubs got even though it's
still you know like existential crisis
but there has
there have been a lot of security um and
support mechanisms but this is just
because there were people talking and
doing the work day to day day to day
and convincing and saying okay this is
the situation this matters we need this
and i think this study i was mentioning
before the club culture study with all
these hard facts it really
[Music]
reached the ears of the government
and
changed something i mean it was all over
the press this number because it was so
impressive and
um
it's just a number but it was really
powerful i think yeah and you see
this positive aspect from the top
continuing with the change of
government in berlin
so yeah right now we are in in
in that situation that we have like
a good way of communication with the
government and but it's constantly
changing and it's always a process and
you have to always renew it and
especially now we don't know how the
government of berlin will look like it's
still you know in the process of finding
itself
but the last four years we have been in
a good situations
so far that we had like a good relation
with the cultural senate
who was
like understanding the needs of club
culture because we were lucky that this
was kind of a part department who
have been to a club before and who know
what it's doing it is doing to the
people there
but most of the time we have this
problem that people are talking about
club culture but they have actually no
idea what they are talking about so
really like research about this and
making this clear is changing something
because people can understand and we can
make people and powerful situ like
positions make understand and
maybe they could hold parliament in
berghein
and maybe like i think we are very far
away from that i mean we have all this
stigmatization going on with club
culture and
i agree um yeah
i wasn't serious
and we haven't got long left so as much
as i would love to carry on talking
about this i don't know if any of you
would like to add to any of those points
i just i just want to add once one thing
and when we're talking about a dialogue
between science and club culture we all
should also see like the the kind of
entanglement between all of this i mean
i'm definitely not the only scientist in
berlin who's going like during the
weekend dancing on the dance floor and
there's enough students who are also
dancing so i think there's already a
kind of conversation happening that
needs maybe to be a little bit more um
built and then constructed but that's
just a synonym but uh but yeah but we're
where a bunch of scientists were also
part of the community as well maybe just
to add this so this uh survey we are
preparing right now we we did with the
support of a researcher and psychologist
from the university in bielefeld
zainab de mia and as well with the house
of research in berlin and as well we
work together with a university
but i really think that this can happen
so much more and yeah i totally agree
with you
great sarah anything to add
[Music]
i would add that
djs also have a
responsibility and
producers
because we are talking more about clubs
now but there are people who are making
the music and profiting off of the music
and i mean this is a whole nother panel
probably but um
i yeah i just want to encourage people
music lovers djs producers to um
go on the journey to learn where the
music comes from and not just take
things and sample things without asking
someone and just be more aware and maybe
work a more
you know collaborative ways
i think that's a really important point
because
i think club culture can only survive if
everybody
takes responsibility for their part in
it and how we further it
um to finish
i would just like to ask you to share
with the audience
if there was one
event
one thing or one experience
that you could recommend to people that
they should try
in relation to clubs or safer spaces
what would that space be and i think we
have three minutes so
anybody want to start
i can start but this was com what comes
to my mind and what i rediscovered
lately is um
the monster runs club in friedrichshain
and
um it's whole it's a karaoke club but
it's holding amazing drag shows and
especially they're always happening
every tuesday
and i would really recommend
everybody to go there and have this
experience of community
thank you i'm going to be doing that
i don't have like one experience coming
to my mind but i think i would just
invite i guess people to stop consuming
the club culture in berlin as some kind
of thing to perform and to to say oh
i've been to that club and i've been to
that party but instead just being more
interested in music and more interested
in being in the
in the moment and it's totally fine if
you don't go to the last very trendy
club but you go to the small party where
music is also very good that's actually
why i asked the question because i
wanted to go away from somebody googling
where's the best place to go in berlin
for people who actually experience it
and you sarah come to my party
and for me i would just say personal
experience i would always recommend a
sound system a good sound system because
you actually feel the music
and it may sound cliche but it's really
true i think my spiritual experiences in
clubs have always been in front of a
sound system and it's just feeling
internal and really hearing the music
how it was supposed to be heard
and sadly that's it we had some
questions which we haven't got to i'm
sorry but thank you for everybody that
sent in some questions
and thank you for joining us
and thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you